on a entendu cet agriculteur dans ce
reportage d'hier quand on est petit on
maîtrise mieux sa vie alain de l'angle
vous vous comprenez oui c'est vrai que
ça peut plus producteurs comme le
consommateur la notion de transparence
la notion d' échanges de liens
ll est fondamental que pas résoudre
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure tous
forcément tous les volumes et toutes les
situations mais on voit bien qu'il ya
cet aspect de petite taille est
compatible avec ses circuits courts mais
cela dit la notion de recherche de la
transparence de connaître la vérité
c'est important et on a vécu sans doute
trop d'années où les produits ont été
marqués t et marc était des fois sans
vouloir montrer les choses telles
qu'elles étaient plutôt on a le souvenir
de choses d'un pot de lait qui montrait
un yaourt et on sait très bien que c'est
plus fait comme ça quoi donc ça peut
faire rêver les gens mais il faut faire
attention de ne pas s'écarter trop de la
réalité et montrer les choses telles
qu'elles sont et vous disiez les
intermédiaires reste néanmoins
indispensable dans l'agriculture
évidemment pour distribuer vos produits
ben je crois que si vous allez à rungis
et vous dites que le marché de rungis ne
sert à rien je pense que il ya des gens
qui vont soulever et on les parisiens
risquent de manquer de nourriture très
vite que donc on voit bien qu'il ya
aussi ce besoin de complémentarité de
d'acteurs alors ces circuits courts ça
représente à peu près 6 à 7% des les
achats alimentaires denise vuillon est
ce qu'il ya un regain d'intérêt ce que
vous sentez vraiment que les français
ont davantage vers ces circuits courts
voilà moi j'ai bien entendu dans le
reportage qui était intéressant c'est
que pratiquement à 100% les gens vont
ont besoin d'abord de se contacter de
liens il ya en soi
de retour à la terre ça c'est et au plan
aussi qualitatif quand on voit quelqu'un
il ya la question de confiance comme tu
disais tout à l'heure on sent que c'est
très important
c'est vraiment important et il voit là
bas nous ça fait quand même vingt ans
qu'on a commencé c'est ce concept mais
il ya toujours plus de demandes